un anniversaire célébré avec faste à
lourdes il y a un siècle et demi tout
juste la vierge marie apparaissait à
bernadette soubirous cinquante mille
pèlerins étaient réunis pour l'occasion
c'est aussi un enjeu économique
considérable pour la ville nous avons
suivi la journée aux côtés de l'arrière
petite nièce de bernadette soubirous
françoise soubirous sur place muriel la
saga olivier combe dans la rue
bernadette soubirous voici la maison de
bernadette elle appartient encore à ses
descendants et notamment à cet enfant
françois souvignon l'arrière petite
nièce est naturellement devenu
propriétaire de la boutique de souvenirs
jouxtant la maison familiale en vue du
commerce et la maison et c'est aux
visites des pèlerins qui le souhaitent
dans la famille soubirous le commerce
est une chose la religion on est une
autre tout aussi importante
on est croyants dans les faits pas
croyable oui d'ailleurs sur la lune et
tous trouvent cela les 109 la semaine
prochaine pour s'insérer atomique
l irremplaçable d'ailleurs la famille
personne ne se rappelle bernadette et
elle est inestimable
il faut dire qu'elle en déplace des
foules bernadette jusqu'à 50000
personnes sont venues assister à la
messe commémorative des apparitions de
la vierge marie à la jeune béarnais
c'était ici dans cette grotte il y a
qu'en cinquante ans jour pour jour c'est
quelque chose que tu as dedans et qui
t'attendent de l'ofppt temps de la
protège te donne la force de continuer
soit c'est magnifique c'est adorable
c'est sûr on va revenir
lourdes est devenue la deuxième ville
hôtelière de france après paris et
accueille 6 millions de visiteurs par an
tout cela grâce à bernadette une jeune
fille issue d'une famille très pauvre